since the pandemic started the money
supply within the u.s has risen by 6.3
trillion dollars this is equivalent to a
monthly increase of 233 billion dollars
a daily increase of 7.7 billion dollars
and an hourly increase of 324 million
dollars clearly the money printing and
quantitative easing have gotten way out
of hand over the past two years and now
we're facing the disastrous consequences
of these economic policies last month we
saw an inflation rating of 8.6
which is the highest reading in 40 years
meanwhile average gas prices across the
us have rocketed to four and a half
dollars and i don't think we even need
to discuss housing to make things worse
it seems like it's going to take several
months if not a few years for inflation
to cool down but even if inflation were
to go to zero tomorrow all of the price
hikes that we've already seen are here
to stay for prices to actually go down
we would need deflation or some radical
change within supply and demand so
chances are prices will likely just
continue to go up but why did the fed
even allow for this many just assume
that the fed is filled with a bunch of
idiots who don't know what they're doing
but i don't think this is completely
true
the fed has some of the best economists
in the world on their side so it's very
likely that the fed did consider this
outcome they simply decided that the
potential consequences were worth the
risk but why do we even have the fed in
the first place and why did they print
money it seems like things were way
better before the fed was even a thing
in fact between 1776 and 1902 there was
literally zero inflation but ever since
the fed was created in 1913 the u.s
dollar has only gone down in value in
fact the us dollar has lost 98 percent
of its purchasing power since the fed
was created and that was as of 2010 the
number is probably over 99
today
this is obviously no coincidence so why
don't we just close down the fed and
stop printing money
well to really understand why the fed is
even a thing we have to take a look back
at history and see how things were
before the fed the fed is actually not
the first time that the us has
experimented with the idea of a national
bank in fact the us has played with
national banking since the late 1700s at
the time the national government was
extremely weak both politically and
economically the vast majority of power
was given to state governments so that
they could better tend to local needs
while this might sound great at first
glance this made the national government
rather useless they weren't able to
achieve national goals such as paying
off war debt stabilizing the currency
and rebooting the economy so the
founding fathers eventually decided to
replace the articles of confederation
which was the original document that
governed the us with the new and
improved us constitution this gave the
national government substantially more
power and treasury secretary alexander
hamilton wanted to leverage his power to
establish a national bank he felt that a
national bank would help establish
economic stability within the us and
while he did face some opposition he
would eventually get a switch in
february of 1791 when president
washington signed the bill into law
several months later in december of 1791
the first bank of the us would open for
business at first the bank primarily
dealt with the national matters for
example they collected tax revenue
distributed funds across the us and paid
for various programs and loans something
that was off limits however was buying
u.s government bonds the founding
fathers feared that this was not only an
inflation risk but that this would cause
the public to lose trust in the national
bank this also meant that the national
bank did not set monetary policy and
they did not act as a bailout service
for dying institutions they were just a
regular old bank that happened to be
used by the national government as well
as the public despite this the existence
of a national bank was still a hot topic
for the next two decades most of the
people who initially opposed the bank
still opposed it in 1811 when the bank
was up for recharter and given that the
federalist party had lost the white
house the bank would eventually be shut
down in 1811. just one year after this
however the war of 1812 would begin
which once again introduced economic
instability this gave supporters of the
bank the perfect opportunity to win over
public support and establish yet another
national bank called the second national
bank of the us
over the next decade this bank would
play a monumental role in western
expansion as they issued loans to
farmers and businesses that were looking
to settle the west despite this major
role in westward expansion they were
still not allowed to set monetary policy
or bailout institutions directly however
it didn't take long for the bank to
start playing with lending policies to
influence national interest rates and
the money supply this freedom didn't
last long though as andrew jackson would
soon come to power
andrew jackson was a major opponent to
banks in general because he simply
didn't trust them about 20 years before
becoming president he sold some land and
the buyers would pay him using paper
notes from a bank but before he could
trade in the paper notes the issuers
would go bankrupt which meant that his
paper notes were worthless in other
words he had essentially given away the
land for free for obvious reasons
jackson was not a big fan of banks
following this experience and he
believed that only silver and gold
should be used for transactions but this
wasn't the only reason that jackson was
opposed to a national bank he felt that
a national bank gave too much power to
too few people he also felt that a
national bank gave the federal
government too much power over state
governments and on top of this he felt
that the national bank did not have
enough regulation so from his
perspective the solution was clear the
national bank had to go
and when he won the 1832 election he
felt that he had affirmation from the
public that that's what they wanted as
well
jackson would veto the recharging of the
national bank and though congress tried
to override his speed toward they would
not be successful jackson would pay off
the entire national debt by selling
federally owned land and cutting
spending substantially he would divide
the remaining reserves amongst the state
banks and with that the us would enter a
period with no national bank this
actually worked out great for quite some
time and it seemed that there was no
need for a national bank but eventually
the civil war would roll around which
not only devastated the economy but
resulted in loads of debt and this time
there was no national bank to maintain
stability and keep debt under control
which led to banking panics becoming
rampant if you're not familiar with what
a banking panic is it's basically when a
bunch of people become fearful that a
bank is not liquid enough so they all go
to withdraw their money at the same time
and when a bunch of people do this it
results in the bank actually becoming
illiquid the us sausage panics almost
every decade there was one in 1873 one
in 1893 and one in 1907. there was also
two close calls in 1984 and 1890. during
this time period people lived in
constant period that their bank could
collapse at any time and it was more
popular than ever to just store gold
under a mattress the us put up with this
uncertainty for several decades but the
1907 banking panic would end up being
the last draw the public was sick of
living in constant fear of a financial
collapse and the government was sick of
constantly dealing with economic
instability so the government got
together and hashed out the details of a
new national bank and eventually in 1913
they would pass the federal reserve act
which established a fed that we all love
and hate today
as we can see from history there needs
to be some sort of central financial
body to ensure national financial
stability this isn't to say that a
decentralized system is impossible but
thus far a centralized system has simply
been far easier to establish and
maintain so alright the existence of the
fed makes sense but why are they so
reckless with inflation i mean this is
literally the third time that we're
seeing high inflation within the past
hundred years well the thing to keep in
mind is the fed is not trying to
eliminate inflation by any means in fact
they want inflation not eight or ten
percent inflation but two or three
percent inflation so whenever we're
under that target rate like we were
doing the cobit recession the fed will
lower rates and print money and whenever
we're above that target rate like we are
right now the fed will increase rates
and engage in monetary tightening but
why even play this difficult balancing
act and artificially create inflation
well there's a few reasons for this
starting with encouraging spending and
investing every year that you simply
hold cash in a savings account you're
basically penalized two to three percent
this discourages people from holding
cash in a bank account instead they end
up either spending the money or
investing the money the government
doesn't really care which one you do
because both of them help the economy
and gdp there's actually a fun economic
three surroundings phenomenon called the
paradox of thrift the theory states that
rising personal savings is detrimental
to economic growth here's the thing
companies and industries become more
efficient and productive with time this
means that the cost of goods are
naturally deflationary over the long
term i mean just think about how much tv
and computer prices have come down over
the past 30 years i bet most of us would
not buy an aka tv right now because we
know that they'll be way cheaper in 5 or
10 years and that's with inflation if
there was no inflation it would just be
even more beneficial to wait it out and
as more people put out such purchases
their savings will go up which according
to the paradox of thrift is detrimental
to economic growth so one of the key
reasons the fed supports inflation is to
maximize gdp another key reason is to
decrease the debt load it's no secret
that the federal government has both
loads of debt and inflation
significantly helps with handling this
debt here's the thing over time debt
payments remain constant however with
inflation it becomes easier and easier
to earn money which in turn means that
it becomes easier and easier to make
your monthly payment now of course the
government is still taking on way too
much debt but that's a whole different
story by maintaining low but persistent
inflation they're able to ease the
burden of debt payments not just for
themselves but for everyone in the us
who's in debt if you're not willing to
play the game how they want it though by
investing and taking on good debt
inflation is just constantly screwing
you over
at the end of the day money printing and
inflation are not that great for the
average person it makes it way harder to
carry on daily life and nearly
impossible to achieve things like home
ownership but despite this the fed won't
stop printing money anytime soon
sure they might fall back for a little
until inflation cools down but sooner or
later they'll be printing money once
again because it protects national
interests it boosts gdp makes the debt
burden easier to handle and most
importantly it allows the government to
make up for their massive deficit as an
everyday person we can complain about
this all we want or we can play the game
how they want it we can invest in stocks
real estate leverage low interest rates
and protect ourselves as much as
possible from inflation or we can do
nothing and remain a part of the middle
class that constantly just keeps getting
poorer and poorer to me the choice is
clear but that's just what i think would
you guys prefer zero inflation comment
that down below also drop a like if you
hope that inflation cools down sooner
rather than later and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
for your video ideas and consider
subscribing see more questions that
logically answered but until then i'm
hari i'll see you guys on the next one